hey guys I'm Brent Rose writer and guy
who wishes he had three hands so here at
Wired we've talked a lot about mixed
reality which you might think of as a
hybrid between the virtual world and the
real one we've seen a lot of really cool
theoretical applications for it already
but today we're here at NASA's Jet
Propulsion Laboratory to see how they're
using bleeding edge technology like the
microsoft hololens right now to design
spacecraft and chart missions on Mars
spoiler alert it's even cooler than it
sounds welcome to Mars
cool thank you good to be here so this
device is tracking you as you moves you
can walk anywhere in this room okay
ouch down look at the rocks as you look
around everything you're seeing is real
data sent back by either the curiosity
Mars rover or by satellites and women is
it photos or is like a 3d scan these are
actual photos it's gorgeous it's just
like there's a 60-inch TV in front of me
and I'm going to couch six feet away
it's basically offering me a window into
this alternate reality where I'm
standing on Mars but I can still see my
periphery and stress tested a little bit
I'm just going to run around the room a
little bit it's amazing though there's
no lag you know you don't get the
terrain experience which is a little bit
disconcerting like you see these hills
and you're not climbing up or going down
but everything was moving in real time
which is kind of amazing I could totally
see myself overlaying this on a
treadmill certainly explore two miles of
the Martian landscape from the comfort
of my gym you might want to be able to
move around
we have a way to shoot okay do that here
tap gesture that we practice OOP and in
town again
Boop hey it really looks like where the
floor is is where the rocks are once I
start getting really close there's a
little bit resolution that's some good
compression guys using Pied Piper you
hear things about hololens being sort of
a narrow window and despite that I found
myself incredibly immersed in the world
I think we're just naturally drawn to
focus on the most interesting thing that
you're seeing nothing was more
interesting than walking around on a
natural Martian landscape why did you
guys decide to choose the hololens
instead of one of the virtual reality
viewers we need to be able to allow a
scientist or an engineer to confidently
and comfortably walk around on the
Martian surface
while they might be in a crowded office
can you add notes or could you draw on
it like that I write
Bowie was here and Tatian of the Martian
surface is a feature that we're looking
at implementing one way you might want
to think about it is just turning Mars
into a whiteboard what you just
experienced is a mission operational
tool with a small set of scientists we
want to put them right beside the rover
that they're using to explore is this
something that anybody could download
and check out Mars on their own we
recently announced a public version of
the experience at the Kennedy Space
Center this summer
we're going to bring a full-scale model
of the 2020 Mars rover right here into
the room BAM
a very human thing that happens when you
put your hands into view around an
object you really gain a whole new level
of intuition about how large something
is I find myself being like a little bit
precious around it I don't want to like
knock into it anything parts of what is
nice about protospace is that you can
cut into any of these pieces if this
were some and over you could sit in the
seat and be like oh no you look
obviously we're going to need a little
bit more Headroom there because you
could see this is something you need hit
your head on or if you need to be able
to get your hand back there to tighten
the screw and you won't fit that's an
adjustment you can make before you even
start prototyping in the physical space
so I can take this real rocket or
whatever it actually is called and I can
see where it fits here and it lines up
down to the screw holes are you working
on ways where you can manipulate the
objects with your hands being able to
pull things apart and to be able to sort
of take things away place them in
different positions while the people are
seeing it is a feature that we're
developing right now so if you had like
a hard day designing the rover you could
just go all office space smash the hell
out of it and then just regenerate it
and start from scratch the next day now
you can maybe do that I don't know that
you'd want to let any of your co-workers
know that you were doing that but okay
so we've been seeing some really
interesting implementations of how you
guys are using hololens on earth how are
you using it off the planet
we sent two of the hololens devices to
the International Space Station where we
were able to talk to astronaut scott
Kelly and from our computer we're able
to then annotate his world I mean think
about it
International Space Station's perhaps
the most complicated machine up about
with the technology now we can put any
number of people with the astronaut at
the same time
so what did we learn here today by
bridging the gap between the digital
world and the real one we can interact
with incredibly detailed models in ways
that we never could before pointing and
tapping at a computer screen simply
pales in comparison the difference is
that mixed reality and the hololens puts
the real you into the experience in a
way that's truly exciting but what do
you think is mixed reality as cool as
virtual reality and all its video gaming
poorni potential let us know what you
think in the comments below subscribe to
Wired if you haven't already make sure
you check out our other videos from NASA
and from the Nottie virtual world thanks
for watching